shockingly the role that I most want to
play is producer I want to be
responsible for bringing great projects
to the screen putting men and women of
all ages sizes ethnicities sexual
orientation to work I just I like
diversity and I want to bring stories
that haven't been told yet and to the
screen so oddly enough producer I don't
have just one favorite movie i have
several and i know that they're my
favorite because no matter what i have
to do any given day if one of these
movies is on i'm going to be late for
whatever it is so I will say Shawshank
Redemption Driving Miss Daisy the color
purple all three of those and recently
Oh Betty a baby to whatever happened to
Baby Jane it's one of my new favorites
I have sort of sort of been approached
to do Broadway but people probably don't
know this I have severe severe stage
fright and I don't think that that's
ever gonna change and you could always
know what I'm really nervous because I
just start just sweating profusely but
you know I also think the things that
scare you are the things that you should
definitely do and try and so one day but
not tomorrow oh you know I'm scared
I would recommend for anyone planning to
break into the business the same thing
that my mother always taught me or told
me and that is to get trained you have
to be trained at any job you take on
whether it's learning how to make fries
at a fast-food restaurant or you know
becoming a doctor you have to be trained
it isn't as easy as it looks so start
with training and put your best effort
forward and I think the rest works
itself out
my upbringing in Alabama made me the
person that I am today I am a little
nutty pretty smart eager to learn and
family oriented and my mother was a big
staunch believer in education so I think
your upbringing informs your work and I
definitely helped me and it definitely
made me embrace Who I am so you know I'm
a southern girl and I'm appreciative of
the fact that I get to be a southern
girl as a nurse a southern girl as a
maid and the help just different
versions of what I know and so embrace
your roots it makes you who you are